[موسيقى]
ادار المنتخب المغربي مبارياته في هذه
النسخه من كاس الامم الافريقيه بشكل جيد
حتى الان اذ تاهل الى دور ال 16 قبل خوض
مباراته امام زامبيا بعدما ضمن التواجد
ضمن المنتخبات الاربعه المحتله للمركز
الثالث لكن المدرب وليد الرجراجي شدد على
ان فريقه مطالب بالفوز وضمان صداره الم
العه السادسه وكان منتخب اسود الاطلس
المرشح بقوه للقب هذه النسخه من الكان قد
تربع على صداره المجموعه برصيد اربع نقاط
بعد فوزه في الجوله الاولى على تنزانيا
بثلاثه اهداف قبل ان يخسر نقطتين ثمينتين
بعد من قاد الى التعادل مع الكونجو
الديمقراطيه بهدف لكل منهما في مباراه وجد
فيها الرجراجي نفسه في قلب عاصفه اعلاميه
بعد اتهامه بالتورط في ت تقات عنصريه ضد
قائد المنتخب الكونغولي ش س
بمبا لم يتحدث ابدا عن العنصريه خلال
مقابلاته من هنا نعلم ان المجتمع مريض منذ
اللحظه التي قال فيها ان لديه كلمات لا
استطيع تكرارها اتجه الكل على الفور الى
لون مختلف قيل انني قلت شيئا ما عنصري
اصبح الوضع مسموما سواء كان ذلك من الجانب
الكونغولي او المغربي هناك اشخاص سيئون من
الى الجانبين للاسف انهم بشر انا في
الملعب لتهدئه الامور لم يحدث اكثر من
شجار لاعب محبط ومدرب محبط انتهى الامر
بالنسبه
لي في المقابل سيحاول منتخب زامبيا التمسك
بامال في التاهل للدوري المقبل للبطوله
التي توج بها عام
2012 واكد افم جرانت مدرب زامبيا ان فريقه
سيدخل المباراه بكل قوه رغم صعوبه مهمه
امام المغرب ويحتل منتخب زامبيا المركز
الثالثه برصيد نقطتين وهو الرصيد نفسه
لمنتخب الكونجو الديمقراطيه صاحب المركز
[موسيقى]
الثاني